you know who's doing it right yoga  nobody talks nobody complains you never  have to hear that meathead in the  background groaning it's great it's just  freeing it's relaxing its kind of place  you go and you just forget about  everything including your girlfriend or  your problems you just need for an hour  you can just release and just let go and  you just stare off and you think what it  would be like to be problem free and  that's the nice thing it's an hour of  your day and it's discipline breathing  it's just discipline breathing not a  damn damn you know who's doing it right  your grandparents because they don't own  a cell phone but on the off chance that  they do they're certainly not blasting  with unimportant text because they don't  know how